rahul 'he's two favorite foods are
bagels and pizza let a represent the
event that he eats a bagel for breakfast
and let B represent the event that he
eats pizza for lunch fair enough
on a randomly selected day the
probability that Rahul will eat a bagel
for breakfast probability of a is 0.6
let me write that down
so the probability that he eights eats a
bagel for breakfast is 0.6 the
probability that he'll eat a pizza for
lunch probability of event B so the
probability of we did that in that red
color the probability of event B the
eats a pizza for lunch is 0.5 and the
conditional probability that eats a
bagel for breakfast given that he eats a
pizza for lunch so probability of event
a happening that he eats a bagel for
breakfast given that he's had a pizza
for lunch is equal to 0.7 which is
interesting so let me write this down
the probability of a given given that B
is true given B is not 0.6 it's equal to
0.7 and because these two things are not
the same because probability of a by
itself is different than the probability
of a given that B is true this tells us
that these two events are not
independent that we're dealing with the
dependent probability this shows us the
fact that B being true has changed the
probability of a being true this tells
us that a and B are dependent d pendant
and so when we start thinking we'll
actually let's just said let's just
before I start going on on my little
soapbox about dependent events let's
just think about what they actually want
us to figure out
so the probability the probability that
he eats the probability of a given B is
equal to 0.7 that's what we wrote right
over here based on this information what
is the probability of B given a so they
want us to figure out the probability of
be given probability of B given a that's
what they wants to figure out the
conditional probability that Rahul eats
pizza for lunch given that he eats a
bagel for breakfast rounded to the
nearest hundredths so how do we think
about this and I encourage you to pause
this video before I work through it so
I'm assuming you've given a go at it so
the best way to tackle this is just just
think about well what's the probability
that both a and B are going to happen
well the probability of a and B
happening and let me do this in a new
color
the probability of a and B happening a
and B I want to stay true to the colors
is equal to there's a couple of ways you
could you could write this out this is
equivalent to this is equivalent to the
probability probability of a given B
given B times the probability of B and
hopefully that makes sense
it probably the B happens and that given
that B it happened the probability that
a happens and that would also be equal
to so obviously this is a and B is
happening or you could view it the other
way around you could view it as the
probability that B the probability that
B given a happens given a happens times
the probability of a times the
probability of a this also makes sense
what's what what what's the probability
that a happened and that given a happen
what's the probability of B you multiply
those together you get the probability
that both happened so why is this
helpful for us well we know a lot of
this information we know the probability
of a given B is 0.7 so let me write that
I'll scroll down a little bit this is
0.7 we know that the probability of B is
0.5 so this is 0.5 so we know that the
probability of a and B is the product of
these two things that's going to be
0.35 7 times 5 is 35 or I guess you
could say half of 0.7 is 0.35 0.5 of 0.7
and that is going to be equal to what we
need to figure out probability of B
given a times probability of a but we
know probability of a we know that that
is 0.6 we know that this is 0.6 so just
like that we could we've set up a
situation in equation where we can solve
for the probability of B given a the
probability of B given a notice let me
just rewrite it or right over here
actually I'll write this part first the
pro point six zero point six times the
probability of B given a times that
right over there and I'll just copy and
paste it so I don't have to keep
changing colors that over there is equal
to 0.35 is equal to 0.35 and so to solve
for the probability of B given a we can
just divide both sides by 0.6 0.6 0.6
and we get the probability of B given a
is equal to like in our calculator out
so 0 0.35 divided by divided by 0.6 and
we deserve a little bit of a drumroll
here is 0.5 8 3 3 keeps going they tell
us to round to the nearest hundredth so
it's 0.5 8 is approximately is
approximately 0.5 8 so another so this
is equal to 0 or I'll say approximately
equal to 0.58 once again verifying that
these are dependent the probability that
B happens given a has is true is higher
than just the probability that B by
itself or that without knowing anything
else just the probability of B is lower
than the probability of B given that you
know given that you know a has happened
or
event a is true and we're done